hello my name is christian conrad i'm at
the university of bristol and i'm
presenting a joint work with sanjiv
khanna who's at the university of
pennsylvania
so this work is about optimal bounds for
dominating set and graph streams
so this work addresses the data
streaming setting in a data streaming
setting we assume that we have only
sequential access to the input that is
the input items arrive in some arbitrary
order at the algorithm the algorithm
process and processes them as they come
in
we only allow the algorithm to make a
single pass over the data so this is a
restriction we have in this work of
course multiple passes are also
conceivable in this model
now the key feature of the data
streaming setting is that we have only
sub-linear space in the size of the
input um because otherwise if we had
linear space of course we could just
store the entire input as we're
processing the stream so space is sort
of small space is the key feature of
this model
in our settings since we're addressing
dominating sets so that's a graph
problem
we look at graph streams
we distinguish here between two models
so there's the insertion only model in
the insertion deletion model
in the insertion only model we assume
that the edges of the input graph arrive
in arbitrary order
in the insertion deletion model
we might have also deletions edge
deletions that is edges might be
inserted but then later on deleted again
they could also be then re-inserted and
deleted again so for example in these
two pictures here and the top picture
this describes this graph is described
by these four edges that arrive in some
arbitrary order in the insertion only
setting
in this picture here this in fact
corresponds to the input stream here on
the left this describes exactly the same
graph as up here the difference is that
we have edges e5 and d6 so for example
e5
is inserted and deleted inserted
and deleted again so overall at the end
e5 does not survive and
for this reason
yeah these two input streams describe
the same graph
now the goal is in both settings to have
an algorithm that uses space little of n
square which is a priori non-trivial for
very dense graphs so we have at most n
square edges so little of n squares are
priori already non-trivial
now um
what is a dominating set so here's some
input graph g
and then a dominating set is a subset of
vertices such that every every other
vertex is adjacent to one of the
vertices in the dominating set or the
way it's written here the inclusive
neighborhood of the dominating set
is the entire vertex set
then
we will also
use the notion of a cover certificate so
our lower bounds will require
that algorithms output a cover
certificate so a cover certificate
is an assignment or is essentially a
mapping from the vertex set to the
dominating set indicating
which vertex is dominated by which
vertex from the dominating set so
example 2 vertex two here is dominated
by vertex one one is of course dominated
by one itself
three is dominated by four four is
dominated by four itself five is
dominated for example by six but also by
pi four and six is dominated by six
so that's what we mean by a cover
certificate
um then we're interested in a minimum
dominating set so that's the best
dominating set that we could have that's
a dominating set of smallest size here
this one would be of size two
then um
we are interested in approximations um
so we say that a dominating set is an
alpha approximation if its size is
smaller
equal than alpha times the size of a
minimum dominating set so approximation
factors are largely equal to one here
good
now dominating set is the problem that
we address in the data streaming setting
in this work and this uh problem
dominating set is
related to the set cover problem and set
cover has been extensively studied in
the streaming settings so let's start by
pointing out this connection between
dominating set and set cover
so what is set cover about so in set
cover we have a input universe u which
we say is of size n
and we have a family of
sets
so
we have overall m sets all of these sets
are subsets of our universe u
the output then
should be the smallest possible subset
of this family
s that covers the entire universe so the
union of these sets in s prime should be
the entire universe u
then we can also of course talk about
approximation similar to dominating set
so here's the connection between set
curve and dominating set
so here suppose we have a dominating set
instance so we have an input graph g
with vertex set v and h is e then we
want to cover all of v in dominating set
so we could to turn this dominating set
instance into a set cover instance we
can set the universe in the set cover
instance to be equal to v
and
now the set family in a set cover
instance then would be uh the inclusive
neighborhoods of all the vertices so for
example here we have
vertex number four the inclusive
neighborhood would be three four and
five so um this would be one of the sets
because of course if we add
4 to the dominating set then
this means that vertex 3 and 5 is
covered corresponding to a set
consisting of the elements 3 4 and 5.
good so these problems in general are we
can reduce them to each other in linear
time
now in the streaming setting these two
problems are however quite different and
this will become clear in a minute
so let's first look at uh streaming
algorithms for the for set cover
so
um for set cover the typical model
considered in the literature is the set
arrival model so here's an example so
suppose these are our sets in our input
we have six sets and um they are
described here in this table
then
the arrival order the input arrival
order in the stream is
the set arrival order is the following
so we would see
the sets arriving in arbitrary order
that is we see for example here
set 2 arriving which means we get say
for example the identifier of set 2 so 2
and the elements that are contained in
set 2.
then we see set 6 arriving with the
elements that are contained in it so in
other words the entire sets arrive one
by one in the set arrival model
now in this specific model um we know in
fact optimal bounds for one pass
algorithms
so
the known results in the literatures are
as follows
so first of all if we are interested in
a root n approximation
then we can get for set cover an
algorithm with space or the tilde of n
so this
observe that we have m sets in the set
cover instance so the space only depends
on n the size of the universe here and
potentially a log m factor
in here
so um this holds for a root n
approximation so we might ask what
happens if we want something better than
a root n approximation so if alpha is in
little o of root n
then in fact the space that is needed is
n times m divided by alpha
so here the space depends on m and in
fact n times m is roughly the size of
the entire set cover instance recall
that we have m sets in a universe of
size n so we can describe all these sets
with n times m space
so um yeah so this is n times n uh
divided by alpha
now this is interesting because uh it's
a somewhat strange behavior at this
approximation factor of root n we have a
phase transition here so the space is
really very large n times m over alpha
for alpha being little o of root n and
then suddenly at root n there's a jump
um down to space n
so this is uh quite quite interesting
about the set cover problem in the one
pass setting
good okay so let's move on to a
dominating set so for dominating set um
it is much more natural to consider a
edge arrival model similar to in the
insertion only
model graph stream model that we've
discussed previously
so um here suppose we have in fact our
input graph as before then
the set system that i've
shown on the previous slide i've copied
it here and this set system in fact
corresponds to exactly this
input graph here so set four for example
is these elements three four and five
now um for dominating set we don't
assume that all these sets or inclusive
neighborhoods arrive one by one we
assume that the edges of the graph
arrive one by one so for example this
would be a potential input sequence that
we see just the sequence of edges first
four five arrives and one two etc
now um
we can
turn a dominating set instance where the
edges arrive still into a set cover
instance but
we see that then sort of the information
for 5 the h45 would correspond to now
sort of
two the information about two sets that
is
in the set number four we know that the
item five is included so the set number
four corresponding to this vertex we
know that the item five is included but
we also know that in the set number five
the item four should be included
so um if we replicate essentially this
information four five and turn it into
sort of two bits of information then we
would end up with what we could call the
edge arrival set cover problem that is
and we have a set cover instance here
but now not entire sets arrive but only
sort of
every bit is one information that shows
that a specific item is contained in a
specific set
um so we can translate sort of a
dominating set into a edge arrival set
cover instance
and of course this edge arrival set
cover instance has a specific structure
in that um uh information is replicated
in that sense but these two settings are
almost equivalent so
in fact streaming dominating set we can
regard it as edge arrival set cover with
m equals n so n sets overall is
essentially equivalent up to this
duplication of information here
okay now
this problem dominating set or edge
arrival set cover is different to set
cover but nevertheless um
it is of course also very similar at the
same time
in fact if we look at the results for
set cover again then we can
take this specific result here that says
um for
the approximation factor is little of n
then we can leverage and take this
result and apply it for dominating set
as well or for
edge arrival set cover
even in in the insertion deletion
setting this result would hold so for
alpha being in little o of n root n
this immediately translates to the
dominating set problem
so for dominating set we immediately get
the result that space
theta tilde of n squared over alpha
is necessary and sufficient for every
alpha being in the loaf and root n
so
that's pretty good so we've already uh
established um
uh or sorted out the situation for alpha
being uh in little of route n but then
still we have the following open
questions so the first question is
set cover did um admit this phase
transition so for alpha equal
theta of root n the space suddenly
collapses down to n so the question is
whether the same holds true for
dominating set as well and if it does is
it also at the same approximation factor
roughly
root n because
well dominating set in the end is a
harder version of set cover here
then
the other question is
for alpha being at least root n
what about the insertion deletion
setting what if we allow deletions um
does the problem behave differently do
we have a phase transitions
transition as well
so in this work we address these two
questions
and this brings us to
the results that we've got
so the first result is the following
we look at insertion only streams and
we obtain the following result so we
show that there is a one pass streaming
algorithm for dominating set
with approximation factor o tilde of
root n
and space o tilde of n
so in other words
this dominating set behaves similar to
set cover
and we have also a phase transition for
dominating set at root roughly root n we
have
root n and there's some log or polylog
factor as well
then
we also see that this dominating set
algorithm that we designed works as well
for arbitrary edge arrival set cover
instances so it's more general than
it it does not only work for dominating
set with m equals n but for
arbitrary number of sets
now one might ask um so here we have an
algorithm with space o tilde of n we
might ask what happens if we have space
uh smaller than uh you know of n we have
little o of n space
and we prove that essentially if we have
less space than um
n then
we cannot achieve a
little of n approximation so we show if
we have if we want a little of n
approximation then we need space omega
of n over log n so there's not much left
below the space of n for this problem
good
then
we address the insertion deletion
setting so in the insertion deletion
setting we give a lower bound
and we prove that every one pass alpha
approximation streaming algorithm for
dominating set in insertion deletion
streams requires base
omega tilde of n square over alpha
so
observe that this holds for the entire
range of alpha values so there is no
phase transition at alpha equals to root
n
so um the situation is much simpler in
the setting
now um there is this algorithm i've
previously mentioned uh
by assadi khan and lee so this is the
algorithm that matches this n square
over alpha bound or in the set cover
setting this n times m over alpha bound
and
in fact this algorithm is so general
that it
works for as previously mentioned it
works for insertion deletions
setting as well and the edge arrival
setting as well so this lower bound
matches uh this algorithm so in the
insertion deletion setting the um the
situation is then entirely described by
this lower bound and this algorithm
okay
so um yeah i want to present now these
two results in
a bit more detail so let's first look at
the algorithm for the insertion only
setting
now um what we really work with here in
the paper is the bipartite incidence
graph representation of the input graph
that is as follows so if the we have the
input graph on the left then we can
construct the following bipartite
version of it we just put all the
vertices um a copy of the vertices as
our a vertices another copy of the
vertices is b vertices
and then
the vertex
number 4 for example is connected to
vertex 3 and 5 and of implicitly to 4 as
well so we introduce an edge that
connects 4 on the left side to 3 4 and
5.
so um we capture essentially the
neighborhood relationship in this
bipartite graph
then we see that a dominating set in
that sense here it's a dominating set we
have 1.6 included if we highlight these
vertices on the left side 1 4 and 6 then
we see that their neighborhood
of 1 4 and 6 covers all the b vertices
here
so in this representation
the goal is we want to cover b using the
a vertices
and
we will assume that the input to our
algorithm is in fact
an edge arrival stream
of the edges in this bipartite incidence
graph
now uh this covers so this is slightly
more general than having the edges
arriving in the original graph
so it captures even arbitrary edge
arrival set cover instances
we do assume in this presentation though
that m equals n so this arises from a
dominating set instance
okay so let's look first at a slightly
simpler setting
so
again the input is the bipartite
incidence graph and we assume that now
entire neighborhoods of the a vertices
arrive in the stream so this corresponds
to the set arrival setting for set cover
essentially
so um we will first look at how we can
obtain a root n approximation here
so do th we can do the following so for
each incoming neighborhoods the
neighborhoods of the a vertices arrive
in arbitrary order
now if this neighborhood
contains at least root and yet uncovered
elements on the b side then we add this
vertex ai to the dominating set so it's
a greedy algorithm if we cover enough if
we cover at least root and vertices then
let's put this vertex into the
dominating set
now as a post-processing step because
the first step might not cover all the b
vertices vertices so for every yet
uncovered b vertex we add an arbitrary a
vertex that covers this b vertex into
the dominating set
good
now why does this give a root n
approximation
um first of all we see that in step one
while we're processing the stream we
might add at most root and vertices um
to our solution because uh the only
other vertex if it covers yet and root
and yet uncovered elements this can
happen at most root n times
so that's good
now
what we then see in the post-processing
stage
we know now that every vertex every a
vertex that's not in the dominating set
yet
covers less than root n of the uncovered
yet uncovered vertices in the
post-processing step
this has to be the case because
otherwise this vertex would have been
added in the first step
so there we have a sort of a trade-off
here if we now for every b yet uncovered
b vertex we um add a separate set
then um this is this is fine because um
in an optimal solution we know that
these vertices um uh any any other
vertex might cover only at most root n
of these vertices so we trade off a root
n with a one here
so that's fine so we get a uh root n
approximation for this algorithm
good now uh let's uh based on this
algorithm let's move to the edge arrival
setting or the the yeah the setting
where we don't have entire neighborhoods
arriving in the stream
and then of course the main challenge
here is that
we simply cannot assume that we see
these entire neighborhoods at any one
moment the neighborhoods essentially are
they might arrive at arbitrary positions
in the data stream so we don't have all
this information in one go
now our algorithm is also a root n
approximation algorithm but we will
first start with the n to the two third
approximation algorithm that is much
simpler and then i will talk about
modifications of this algorithm that
then give us a root n approximation
so we have a pre-processing step and in
this pre-processing step we
we first take a uniform random sample of
the a vertices
and
every a vertex is included in the sample
with probability one over n to the
one-third so we have a uniform sample of
size roughly n to the two thirds
good now um for every a vertex we
maintain a quantity that we call the
uncovered degree and initially this is
zero
then
as we go along and we process the stream
um so a b is the current edge that we
see
first of all if the b vertex is already
covered in d in the dominating set then
we don't do anything at all
so assume that the b vertex is not yet
covered in the dominating set
then what we do is um we increase the
uncovered degree of the the respective a
vertex that's incident to that on that
edge
good
now only once the uncovered degree of a
vertex of a vertex reaches n to the two
third then we add this vertex to the
dominating set
okay so this is all we do while
processing the stream we uh if the b
vertex is not yet covered then we
increase the uncovered degree and if the
uncovered degree of a vertex
reaches n to the two third then we
included in the dominating set and then
similar to before in the other algorithm
if at the end of the stream there isn't
yet uncovered b vertex then we add an
arbitrary a vertex that covers this b
vertex
so
yeah an arbitrary one
good now what's the analysis of this
algorithm so first of all um we see that
every b vertex that has a degree that is
this least n to the one third log n
will be covered by one of the vertices
added in the
uniform sample in the first step
simply if we have a degree of n to the
one third log n and we sample into the
two third random vertices in the graph
then uh necessarily one of them or with
high probability will be in the
neighborhood of b
so what this means is as while we're
processing the stream um
after having seen n to the one third log
n incident edges to a b vertex
we know or with high probability this
vertex will be covered and in other
words only this first n to the one third
login edges
can contribute to increasing the
uncovered degrees of the a vertices
recalling the algorithm once a p vertex
is covered
nothing happens anymore the uncovered
degrees are not degrees are not
increased
so that means if we take the sum of the
uncovered degrees while we're processing
the stream then we see that well we have
nb vertices and uh each b vertex
contributes with that n to the one third
log n so we know that the sum of
uncovered degrees is at most n to the
fourth log n
so what this means is um
only n to the two third log n a vertices
now
can reach an uncovered degree of n to
the two third and are thus added to the
dominating set so this happens in this
line
so um yeah so the number of vertices
introduced while processing the stream
into the dominating set cannot be too
much it's only end to the two third log
n
so overall steps one and two
pre-processing end while what we're
doing while we're processing the stream
um adds at most n to the two third log n
vertices to the dominating set so that's
not too many even if the optimal
solution
was one or two a very small
dominating set we would still be within
this and to the two third approximation
regime
now um if we look at the post-processing
step then we see the following
so first of all every vertex that's not
included in the dominating set
can cover at most n to the two-third
vertices of those that are left at the
end and the reason for that again is if
this number was bigger then it would
have been added here because then the
uncovered degree would be at least n to
the two third and they would be included
in the dominating set
we also see that each vertex
that is added to the dominating set in
this uh step two so it misses at most n
to the two thirds elements elements
before being added to the dominating set
um uh this is simply because um the
first and to the two third times we just
increase the uncovered degree and only
then it is added but that's okay to miss
into the two third elements before being
added because even if we cover all these
elements individually with separate sets
then we only add n to the two third
sets to the solution while sort of um we
add in the optimal solution one vertex
so there's again this trade of one
versus n to the two third and this
ultimately gives
an end to the two-third log in
approximation this algorithm
good
now um
here i've copied this algorithm again
and i will now step by step modify this
algorithm
and
display our n to the one third sorry and
to the one half log n approximation
algorithm
so the first problem that we see is that
in step one we took this uniform random
sample where we add roughly into the
two-third vertices to d but that's too
much because
if the optimal solution was of size one
or a constant size then we can have only
root n elements in the in our solution
to have a root n approximation factor
similar
in this step uh here in step two when we
add
an a vertex to the solution um that we
only do that when the uncovered degrees
n to the 2 3 so we might
miss these into the 2 3 b vertices which
is also too much
so we can miss it at most root n of
these so what we can do is the following
um let's just replace these numbers and
take us a smaller sample and
here we just use the number n to the one
half in order not to miss too much
then this of course has implications to
for the algorithm and the implication is
that now the sum of uncovered degrees um
suddenly becomes um
quite a bit bigger so the sum of
uncovered degrees would suddenly be n
root n log n
and
from this we deduce that in fact
all n a vertices may now reach this
uncovered degree of root n in this step
and we would add all of these a vertices
now to our dominating set and that's of
course not good because then the
dominating set is way too big
so to fix this what we can do is the
following
we add here a um a sampling step so we
only introduce one of these a vertical
vertices in the dominating set then with
a probability of one over root n
and this guarantees of course that we
don't add too many elements to the
dominating set so now in step two we
also only uh out roughly root n elements
to the dominating set so that's good
but of course sort of the inner logic of
the algorithm is broken now
we can't just
ignore the vertices that were missed
and um uh
we we need to sort of make sure that uh
the a vertices that we haven't
introduced in the dominating set
something happens to them later on
so what we do is the following we repeat
in fact the entire process and give
these a vertices that
were missed a second chance to be
included a little bit later again
so in fact the way it works we introduce
multiple layers and the parameter i
corresponds now to the layers so i is an
integer starting at 1 2 3 etc so
whenever the the uncovered degree of a
vertex becomes say root n 2 root n 3
root n
the vertex has a chance to be included
in the dominating set and now we ramp up
these
inclusion probabilities so in the
beginning it's a moderate probability of
say 2 over root n then becomes 4 over
root n 8 over root n so it exponentially
increases
so after log n
sort of
steps then we know that the inclusion
probability will actually be one and
these vertices actually end up in the
dominating set
and this is the entire algorithm so the
introduction of these layers really
allows us to improve the approximation
factor
now in terms of analysis um just very
briefly um it can be seen that so if we
define a level i edge to b1 that
increases the uncovered degree of an a
vertex
where the current uncovered degree is
already between i times root n and i
plus 1 times root n so we call this a
level i edge
then we we can prove that the number of
level i edges
in fact goes down quite quickly so it
will be into the um three half divided
by two to the i so
they decrease exponentially in i
and this also means that the number of a
vertices that reach such an uncovered
degree
decreases also exponentially so
to reach an uncovered degree of i root n
we have only n divided by 2 to the i
minus 1 many
so what this means if we look at this
number n divided by 2 to the i minus 1
and we look at the inclusion probability
we see that
we add an expectation so all of this
holds an expectation we add only two
root n a vertices per level that we have
so that means overall we have these log
n levels because then the inclusion
probability becomes large equal to one
and therefore we added most um or we add
root n log n a vertices
through while we're processing the
stream
now
this is sort of the key argument of all
of this now um for step three again we
add additional vertices um but as before
we've seen this uh sort of twice now um
there's a similar argument that
basically shows that
this step 3 doesn't worsen the
approximation factor and this gives us
this n to the one half log in
approximation
good
okay good um now then i'm going to move
on to
the insertion deletion setting and i
will present a lower bound for the
insertion deletion setting
so and then again the key difference of
course in the insertion deletion setting
is that
we not only have edge insertions but
these edges can be deleted later again
now our technique for proving this lower
bound
is this connection to communication
complexity to one-way communication
complexity
and we will have two parties alice and
bob
now the way the
input will be constructed is as follows
alice will have some edges of our input
graph we call these edges e1
based on these edges e1 alice needs to
send a message to bob
now bob
will hold edge deletions so these
deletions d they necessarily are a
subset of e1
because of course these deletions these
edges must have been introduced before
by
alice so d is a subset of e1
in addition to that
bob will also hold some more edge
insertions e2
so the input graph is then described by
some vertex set v the edge set e1 minus
the deletions union the edges e2 on
bob's side
and um yeah the typical connection here
is that an insertion deletion streaming
algorithm
would yield such a one-way two-party
protocol in this setting and the
connection is that the size of the mesh
message corresponds to the space of the
streaming algorithm
so how do we construct this specific
input
so um
let's first look at what alice holds so
alice's input is as follows
so suppose alice has simply a random
bipartite graph on
two n vertices so we have n vertices on
the left and vertices on the right
now each edge here is included with
probability one half
in addition to that we turn the left by
partition into a click
now the yellow triangle here should
simply indicate that the degree of all
of these vertices is roughly the same so
would be roughly in half here
each degree of these eight increases
good
um so this is alice's input alice sends
a message based on this input and bob's
input then is as follows
so first of all bob has a
an index i which is a random index in n
and it would correspond to a special a
vertex here
so here's the special a vertex
then we said bob has some deletions now
bob will delete edges that were inserted
by alice and
the edges that would be deleted are as
follows so none of the edges incident to
the special ai vertex are deleted so
these edges remain the same so there's
still this yellow triangle here
but for all of the other vertices a1 to
a n except ai we delete all of the
incident edges but
leave n divided by
alpha log n edges so
we needed all but that many um so after
these deletions
each of these vertices has n over alpha
edges left so this is what the red
triangle corresponds to
now um
there will be one additional special
a vertex so
bob has additional edges as well and
they are all incident to this vertex a
prime here
and these edges so there are many of
them they have the following properties
so the next slide explains this a bit
better
so um the edges incident to this one
will be
will also be very many so there's a red
triangle here as well and it will be so
that the union
of the neighborhoods
of this vertex a prime and a i
they cover the entire side on the b side
except a single element bt
so t is a random element here randomly
chosen
so again um
the
enter so the b side is then covered by a
prime a i and there's this one element
left over bt
so this is essentially the this this is
the description of the heart input
distribution
um so what we see here is that um the
optimal solution in this instance will
always be of size three
we can always pick a prime sorry a prime
we can pick
a i and then we pick an arbitrary set
that covers this vertex bt
good
now
let's think about a dominating set
algorithm a streaming algorithm or
protocol in this setting that outputs a
dominating set here
and suppose that this output dominating
set is an alpha approximation so the
output dominating set is d and we know
that since the optimal solution is of
size three
the size of d is at most three times
alpha so it's over alpha
now let's look at
all the sets of a vertices added on the
left side
that are not a i and not a prime so one
of these
these are basically the subset of
vertices with such a red triangle
incident to it
now we know that since bt is not covered
by a i and is not covered by
a prime it must be covered by one of the
vertices with such a red triangle
incident on it
now
how many of these do we have of these
vertices with a red triangle well we
know that they are only at most the
solutions of size at most three alphas
so that most three alpha even minus two
of these if we assume that these ones
are included so at most um of
um
of these vertices are included in the
solution
now
why is what does this mean
so this means that um bob can look at
which elements um
are covered by these ones with the red
triangles so we know that overall
the size of one of these
neighborhoods is
n divided by alpha log n
there are o alpha many of these
so we we can identify bt as one of well
o alpha
alpha times n over alpha log n so the
size of these neighborhoods which is n
over log n
many vertices
so we know that bt is covered by one of
these vertices there are only alpha of
those included the neighborhoods of
these are small so we know that bt must
be one of
n over log log n
different
b vertices
in other words what this means is that
a dominating set protocol with an alpha
approximation factor on this instance
is able to substantially reduce the
entropy of t
so recall that initially t the way it is
constructed is a uniform random element
among n possibilities so nb vertices
after having run the algorithm we know
that t can only be an element among n
over log n many
vertices so the entropy of
t was substantially reduced by this
algorithm
now um
the this idea to
get go from here to get an actual lower
bound is then implemented as follows
so we use
an information complexity approach so we
measure the amount of information about
alice's input that is necessarily
contained in the message that is sent
from our list to bob
now the underlying sort of obstacle
problem the heart problem um
is
what we call the set union problem
so this was uh the complement of this
problem uh
was studied in this assadi human khanna
paper
so here's the underlying problem that we
look at consider a two-party problem
where alice holds a set as one bob holds
the set is two and they're guaranteed
that the union is the entire universe n
but with one element missing
and again this element here would be a
uniform random element
the problem in set union would be to
substantially reduce the entropy of t
so bob doesn't necessarily need to
identify exactly what this missing
element t is but it is enough to simply
reduce to reduce the entropy of t enough
then in this paper 2019 paper it is
proved that the information complexity
of the set union problem is omega of n
so um
yeah so it's almost equally hard as
identifying exactly what he is
now the way we work is first of all
if you recall
bob has chosen this index i uniformly at
random so there's the special set a i
this can be also one out of n
possibilities so this
sounds like a direct sum type of
argument that we can use so we will have
here um a complexity that is n times the
complexity of the underlying problem
now the underlying problem is the set
union problem so this sounds like the um
the complexity should n be n times n n
square which of course cannot be quite
right
but um the reason for that that it's not
quite n n square is the fact that
there's this information overlap between
alice and bob
bob holds these edge deletions in our
setting and
in fact there are only n over alpha log
n edges per a vertex that are unknown to
bob because bob has has these deletions
so in fact the complexity that we get is
this direct sum argument which is uh
multiplies everything by n
times the number of edges that are
unknown to warp a vertex
so um we get this n square divided by
alpha
log n lower bound here
okay good
okay good then um i would like to
conclude so
what are our contributions again so our
contributions are essentially optimal
bounds for dominating set up to polylog
factors in both the insertion only and
the insertion deletion settings
in the ins in the insertion only setting
we saw that there is a phase transition
as well at the factor at the
approximation factor root n in the
insertion deletion setting we proved
this
lower bound that n square over alpha is
best possible
now this algorithm that we have the root
n approximation also extends to set
cover instances in the edge arrival
setting with a space m plus n
and gives the same root n approximation
factor and in a follow-up work we also
show that a lower bound that even in
number in terms of the number of sets in
a general edge arrival setting omega of
m
space is necessary for such a root n
approximation in the edge arrival
setting
and
i would like to conclude with one open
question and that is as follows so
essentially all set cover and dominating
set space lower bounds for streaming
they rely on
an output certificate so
we need a cover certificate for that and
exploit the cover certificate to prove
our lower bounds and the key question
would be
can we
avoid this step can we prove low bonds
for algorithms that don't require to out
that we don't require to output a cover
certificate
good then yeah thanks very much for
listening